this man just threw another no-hitter
his third no-hitter in his illustrious
career fifth pitcher in Major League
Baseball history with 250 more
strikeouts in five seasons at least now
six pitcher in Major League Baseball
history to throw three no-hitters
siyoung Larry Corcoran Bob Feller Sandy
Koufax Nolan Ryan in this guy Justin
Verlander of the Houston Astros right
here in the Rich Eisen show how are you
Justin hey doing great thanks how are
you damn straight you're doing great
so did you wake up dangerous led to use
the Baker Mayfield phrase like did you
know it was a did you feel it that day
what I can say I did I mean I think you
know these things are kind of like
lightning strikes you know you just
never really know I felt pretty normal
day actually kind of fell like crap
warming up so I think that this is kind
of a common theme though you hear like
perfect games no hitters a lot of times
guys don't feel great in the bullpen or
early in the game so how does that see I
mean what do you mean you just like walk
me through for us I guess mortals in a
way Justin what does that mean that
you're not feeling good in the bullpen
well I was kind of all over the place my
command wasn't great and then you know
but I don't put much stock in my
bullpens anyway it's just kind of a
means to get to be my body loose and
then I came out to start the game and
the velocity was a little down and my
command was still a little all over the
place
walked a second better of the game and
you know it was just kind of like
alright well it's gonna be one of those
days gonna have to grind and you know
sir enough slowly but surely things just
started to kind of click a little bit
and about time I you know looked up is
the 4th 5th in and I'm like well well
shoot them
I'm feeling pretty good now and having
grown up a hit so see what this thing
goes and sure enough man was able to
pull it off so that's I was about you
just took my next question is like when
do you look up and see the 0 under the H
column on the scoreboard and start
thinking about it well beside the first
inning I mean it's kind of like the
whole game is always aware that you
haven't given up ahead I guess when it
really starts to click in I think is
after the 6th inning the seventh is like
ok we're getting close nine outs
babe is uh is pretty intense and the
ninth is just kind of like
right well you know let's let it all
hang out not blown - in the ninth
I don't say I've blown you know they're
pretty uh the hitter did a good job
getting a hit off man tonight right a
couple times before so I mean and this
is after having had two already so I
didn't think three was in the cards for
me I just kind of thought it was not
gonna happen you don't get so many
chances and you know sure enough I was
thinking about those I thought about in
the ninth inning the other night as you
know I've been here before and I was
like I don't know if I'll ever get this
close again I definitely don't want to
blow this one well I mean here also I
imagine this was your third one I'm not
terribly familiar as you might be
obviously with your two previous ones
did you have early leads and this one
because this was nothing nothing forever
it felt like forever it was no score in
this one Justin yeah I mean I think the
two previous I definitely had some run
support this one was very different I
mean it's not different for me the way
I'm pitching but it when Augusta the
ninth inning it's like hey if we don't
score here I don't really have a chance
because my pitch count was so high that
I wasn't gonna go I knew I wasn't going
back after the 10th so if we didn't
score in the ninth inning it just wasn't
gonna happen whether I didn't give up a
hit or not in the nines and what is it
about Toronto you're the first pitcher
in the history of baseball Justin
Verlander to throw multiple no-hitters
on the road against the same opponent
what what is it about SkyDome sometimes
sometimes you step on a noun in certain
places it's just like it's a good visual
and I don't really know how to explain
that it's like when I step on the mound
in Toronto I feel like I'm I'm pretty
close to home plate like I dividual
looks good to me so maybe that has
something to do with it I don't know
you're like the antica why I think in
Toronto like you're the opposite of
kauai when you're not going to get any
free meals there Justin I'll tell you
that no no I know I know so walk me
through the one
own a mound visit that you had that day
just yeah it's probably pretty more
interesting than then people would think
I guess it's because it was the ninth
inning it was two outs there's kind of
one of those moments that typically you
don't want to interrupt the flow of the
game so I think that kind of caught a
lot of people's eye that I called that I
call Torinos out to talk and really what
the conversation was about was uh
Pichette who was coming up who had had
three of that's already and I had a good
feel for what he was seeing well and
what he wasn't but he has two different
swings he has a pre two strike swing and
the news two strike swing he shortens up
and has a bit of a two-strike approach
which honestly as I see in this day and
age but I wanted to make sure that he
didn't go to that two-strike approach
earlier in the at-bat because that would
have probably changed a little bit of
the way I attacked him and with the with
the way he does his leg kick and the
rhythm of my mechanics I wouldn't really
be able to see if he was doing it or not
so I told Torinos hey if he does this
earlier than two strikes I need you to
let me know just point to him or
something and say that he was doing this
so I would be aware hmm Justin Verlander
Astros pitchers and song award winner
and certainly a candidate for this
year's award right here on the Rich
Eisen show how often do you think about
that 60-second period at the trade
deadline that no longer exists anymore
a couple of years ago Justin where you
almost were not a Houston Astro you know
I mean I definitely still think about it
it comes to mind you know we go to
detroit detroit comes to us or you know
when i'm reminded that just coming up a
conversation talking about the moment i
mean it was such a hard decision in the
moment and now looking back i mean it
was it was such a if you could have if
you could have said all that's gonna
happen was going to it was going to
happen it was the easiest decision I've
ever made but I mean I had so much
history in Detroit the fan base there my
home was there I grew up there and all
those things come into consideration you
know if it's you know athletes it's not
just it's not just purely a sports
decision it's a family decision and a
life decision and that weighed every on
me ultimately though it came down
it came down to having the opportunity
to win and I mean man that it paid off
pretty immediately when in the
championship in 17 damn straight you're
just winning and winning and winning and
now here you are in a situation where
you're battling your own teammate for
the sayang award Justin it's it's kind
of court what do you have conversations
about that sort of thing open um we
haven't actually directly discussed it
but I mean we definitely Garrett and I
are good friends doing definitely yeah
we have a friendly competition that I
think kind of pushes us both you know
the closest we've come to talking about
anything like that was actually the
other night after his start two starts
ago because I had passed him in
strikeouts like the first time in a year
but of the year and was like I had done
seven straight starts with 10 or more
punch outs like I just gone on some
crazy run and the start after that I
only had four so of course Garrett goes
out punches like 13 or 14 of that next
start and in the shower after the game
I'm like you know I just finally I let
the door open just a little bit you
didn't have to just walk through it you
just like kick the door down you know
it's just like Grand through and anova
took the lead again so that's kind of
the closest we've come to talking about
our kind of friendly competition we got
going on in the shower huh that's where
these conversations take place all the
time like the white shadow I remember
that show although it's the I might be
dating myself you're just in a little
bit when you're on the road and you need
something to watch it's some good old
school sports television from way back
in the time so when it all comes down to
it though obviously the old english d
what you used to wear and how many
people still look to you is as fondly
with all that what does it mean for you
to throw this no-hitter for the same
organization as Nolan Ryan Justin I mean
just incredible obviously you know Nolan
was my idol growing up you know and I
mean I've had some pretty cool moments
already as an astro and one of the
coolest is sitting there pitching in the
playoffs and looking behind home plate
and see and Dolan Ryan fact they're
watching me pitch I mean that's just so
incredible in it still it gives me
goosebumps thinking about it
but you know actually got a text message
from them after the game and you know we
talked I talked to him quite a bit
honestly which is uh I mean if you told
the little kid me that this would be
where I was at
I mean how to called you liar I mean
just getting there you know get another
field that two o'clock and sitting down
and having a conversation with Nolan
about pitching I mean it's a pretty
pretty amazing so what what
conversations can you let me be a flat
wall here a little bit with you and
Nolan Justin well I've been struggling
with my changeup a bit
this was probably a month and a half ago
and you know as Nolan got older in his
career he started developing a great
changeup and started using it a lot
really he kind of he said it kind of
helped him through the last five six
years of his career to succeed and so I
was talking about his grip and his
thought process and it kind of you know
reminded me of some things that I used
to do with my changeup so really this
conversation just kind of spurned some
old thought processes that I had with my
changeup in the past and and really it's
been it's been pretty good I used it a
lot more since we had that conversation
and and it's been a I mean it's still a
weapon that I don't use that often but
it's definitely in my back pocket and it
got better with witted by a few more
minutes left here with Justin Verlander
Astros pitcher eight time American
League all-star and now multiple three
now no hitters on the ledger here on the
Rich Eisen show do you still think the
balls are juiced Justin yes
okay sure I did ask you yes or no
questions so I deserve that answer but
please you know obviously I kind of
voiced my opinion at the at the all-star
break and look I'm I know that we're all
using the same - even in fair playing
field so hey it is what it is my problem
is that it changes the game it changes
the the core of what I think makes
baseball great you know that you don't
see base stolen bases anymore you don't
see you guys getting the runner over
anymore you don't see guys go into a
two-strike approach like I said Bobo
said did you know trying to put the ball
in play
it's just launch angle and hit the ball
over the fence and I don't mind them I
don't mind that because honestly the
game is dictating that you know if
there's so many home runs and walks and
homers are how you're going to
or I mean if you're not gonna string
together three four five six hits and
appending anymore than I mean you have
to try to hit the long ball so I get it
I just you know I think the the proof is
in the numbers I mean you see that
Triple A homers were up 60 percent from
last year and nothing changed with the
baseball and homeowners are up this year
in Major League Baseball so those uh
those decisions are far over my head you
know somebody with MLB I think is you
know has to decide whether this is good
or bad for the game of baseball that's
not my call I just you know one of the
call spade a spade what about the idea
that that along with the shift where
everybody thinks that they have to move
the ball over people you think it has
something to do with it - I do
I mean you see it all the time I mean
this goes back to the same type of talk
where you know why as a left-handed
hitter would you just short nothing try
to put the ball in play now a lot of
people you know say well why don't you
just if your shift they want you to sit
ball the other way I mean when you got
guys throwing 98 miles an hour and you
know for me for instance I you know I'm
throwing mid-90s and my fastball rarely
gets hit on the ground as is it's like a
90% fly ball rate and then most of the
time I'm throwing all speed pitches down
and under your hand so I it's not as
easy as it sounds to just try to hit the
ball to the left side so you know you
got two strikes and you just try to put
the ball in play and set a strike out
well you got five guys on that side of
the field that you're most likely
putting the ball in play - you know it's
it's it's more time they're not going to
end up in and out so you know I get it
like I said I understand why guys are
just not going to strike approaches and
try to hit homers say I I think I think
you've nailed it you nailed it I think
that the balls in the shifts are kind of
leading to this home run era well and
there's also so many pitching changes to
Justin I mean one of the things that's a
throwback of what you did on on Sunday
is that it's the first no-hitter in the
last four that wasn't a team effort you
actually did it yourself
you know and it's just the 40 first
complete game of the year and you
and Game two of the ALCS against the
Yankees three know soon to be three post
seasons ago last pitcher to throw a
complete game in in in the playoffs so
why you know how difficult is it to take
the ball from you Justin walk me through
that process I mean I feel like AJ and
myself have had a really good rapport
you know I've always taught that I'm
gonna be I'm gonna be honest with you
with how I feel and he's always he
always asked me you know how's it going
how you feel and if I you know like the
other night I had 104 pitches after
eight he's like how do you feel that's
so great let's go and that's it that's
pretty much seen the conversation it was
a similar conversation against the
Yankees free playoffs ago um you know I
think I came out with over 100 pitches
and he just kind of looked at me and
gave me a little head nod I reciprocated
it that was it we didn't even really
need to talk about that one but it's got
to be a mentality - right Justin not a
hundred percent yeah I definitely want
the ball and want to stay out there as
much as possible and and you know I got
to give it to organization I mean I I
think you know you see some some teams
trying to do the the opener and and and
not three times through the lineup well
for the first time and I don't know if
ever but for the first time in a long
time relievers have worse numbers in
starters so I mean maybe that'll start
to trend things back the other direction
I don't know but I do find that pretty
interesting maybe add them as they're
getting more and more innings all of a
sudden the numbers are starting to
flip-flop a little bit and starters are
again having better numbers well your
throw back man before I let you go you
play in fantasy football you and a
league got the Astros I am yeah take
DeAndre Hopkins
yeah that's on brand there in Houston
okay and exactly and I got this on to go
with them later but okay I'm excited all
right I gotta get a good thing
and what's job at 12 in the second round
okay well team Lee what's the name
what's your team name is it safely I
haven't named it yet eyes actually woke
up this morning thinking about the guys
I drafted and what to name my team
can we come up with one for you can we
come out my show listeners come up with
it and you either use it or not okay
sure okay okay very good we're very
creative here because the name of our
yeah the name of my team gonna be public
we got to keep it pg-13
no no we've got one we're in the Alice
in Chains fantasy celebrity League and
based off of Andy Reid being at the
center of the coaches picture at this
year's owners meeting and manspreading
it's called man spread in centerpiece
and that and he's our avatar so that's
what we went with just to give you a
okay Justin thanks again really
appreciate the call Congrats
on yet another one and take it easy on
my Yankees if you see them gotta take it
easy you got that's Justin Verlander
Justin at Justin Verlander
you're on the Rich Eisen show for more
of the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV for free on BR
Live or download the Rich Eisen show app